hello this is the session how to be a
compiler my name is Mary Coe that's my
twitter handle and my github handle
pretty much everywhere on the internet
except myspace if you want to try you
can find it it was taken when I
registered it in 2000 you know five or
six I'm fluent from New York City and
based in New York City I work a Google's
web developer relations team my job is
to make you help you make better at web
so if you have any concerns complaints
things that you want to say to people
who's making a bub sunderers / browser
please do use me as a proxy to send
those message and please do come talk to
me
and speaking of web I am primarily a
JavaScript developer and when I'm not
using JavaScript at work I also like to
knit and that's my hobby and when I
learned to code this hobby and work kind
of like married together and I started
doing everything with knitting and
JavaScript so one of the example project
that I do is thing called sweater if I
so should you like to have a
visualization of ugly sweater that's
using a strange loop loop then you can
go in upload the image and then create a
very realistic visualization this
doesn't really translate on the screen
but if you go in the screen then I'm
very proud of how realistic it is to
look I spent a lot of hours looking at
SVG and canvas to have this like right
type of an ash a doe and my type of
phase for this knit so like if you want
to use it
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you but I started code while I
already know knew how to knit and it
became a thing that in order to learn to
code I make something for my other hobby
with his net so the first thing I did
was making no counter my version of
doing to do MVC was making low counter
you know state management browser events
you know saving local data great another
one I did was color helper so if you do
knit and decided to do color work like a
fair isle there's a common technique
amongst knitter to take a
black-and-white picture of yarn that
you're going to use because when you're
making color work you have to make sure
that the colors to colors that you are
using next to each other has a distinct
contrast so that the pattern comes out
and doesn't needi blend it into like
mesh of black or dark green right so
they do this technique of using a cow
farm camera and then put the black and
white filters to define that like okay
it's contrasted enough but if you done
if you done work with color space you
know that's not true like the red and
green might come out as the same black
and white value while it's actually
contrast color having a look at the
color in color right so you know that
was fun projects learning about color
space and vector math and then next I
went into unit processing because I had
this like one time where I was obsessed
with printing out picture in knitwear so
should you have wish to have your cat on
your sweater then you have to do this
interesting thing first of all you have
to have a very low resolution image
because in the sweater you probably have
like eighty pixel 260 pixel as a width
depending on what kind of yarn you use
and also yarn doesn't come in hex code
so you know at most
most you can use like six colors at a
time so you have interesting challenge
of resizing the image and reducing the
noise how do we do that by preserving
the shape how do we reduce the color
posterize issue in there being a whole
bunch of interesting thing that I did
and I made our vice versa in library for
that that was interesting and then I
went into compiler in DSL and you're
like that was kind of jump what the [ __ ]
is that I promise it will make sense in
a minute I'm gonna go into it so this
talk is about alternatively an
introduction to building compiler and I
want to emphasize that it is an
alternate introduction so it is going to
be introductory but also it's alternate
so I am NOT going to talk about
recursion or visitor pattern I'm not
gonna talk about the tools like yak Lex
and never VM it's going to be a
explanation of compiler from the point
of view of knitting person who try to
make compiler for knitting so a
visualization of my target audience is
that if you feel like word compiler is
like a black box where your code gets
sense to and if they are bad they're
chopped forever and cannot come back
that was my understanding of compiler
before going in again I'm a JavaScript
developer like I literally deal with
compilers and I started the dealing with
compiler with like Babel and things and
I was just like very intimidated but
after this talk I hope to like change
the perception by thinking like you know
compilers a box of fun so now that the
expectations are set let's dive into it
so before talking about compilers I need
to explain you what knitting is so that
we are all on the same page so when you
want to make these beautiful sweaters
you go in you download or buy a pattern
in this case I'm showing the free
pattern that you can actually go
download the Knitting comes in two
formats either a glass or knitting chart
pattern so graph is called knitting
chart and this is what I grew up I grew
up in Japan a Japanese knitting
publication is
primarily use chart so I learned to lead
these chart I learned to the H symbols
and I can just dive in look at the chart
and then start knitting however I moved
to United States six years ago and here
we use a putter on the written pattern
which is like this and this is
essentially a step by step word
explanation of that chart that you just
saw so it's two things the same but we
presented in two different thing and I
swear every year some a programmer go
home during a holiday season sitting
next to somebody who is knitting looking
at the pattern and tweet that oh hey
knitting is like code and every time
that happens I guess II see it on the
thread and I'm like listen listen I know
well come through the club so let's dive
into what it looks like so if you do
knit then I hope you have a similar
feeling that knitting is code but if you
don't then you will get it hopefully so
even without knowing anything about
knitting if you or given this piece of
text I think you'd think that this is a
code you can see repeating were like k
maybe kind of like a valuable and a more
distinct one like until remaining or
repeat from which kind of indicates Luke
so on the Knitting is a atomic unit for
knitting is knit and purl so when you
knit that means you are pulling the yarn
from the back of the loop creating this
kind of like heart shape chain together
face of a fabric and then purl is
pushing then you're from the back
creating this like bumpy look and
combination of those two creates a
beautiful patterns usually there is like
knit two together or make one like it's
like a combination but like atomic unit
is just knit or purl so if you go look
into your sweater so the left one is a
two by two ribbing which is very common
in your cuff for the the sweater or the
neckline
it's basically knit knit purl purl knit
knit purl purl knit knit purl purl
repeating all the way up and then the
next one that looks a little more into
get if you look at it it is just a knit
purl yet power power power power purl
kind of like shifting one low below
creating this more in to get patterns so
that's the basic knitting
so let's look into look at this knit and
I'm a JavaScript developer so I'm gonna
show you a JavaScript code and you will
understand why I write JavaScript
because it's so good for knitting I will
explain that later but when you think
about knitting as a code and try to
write a computer code that the browser
understands it is essentially a la
manipulation so let's go see one by one
row below so first one is Co 5 which is
elevation forecast on 5 which means put
D so let's say this is the knitting
needle put five loops on the needle
so basically create a my scarf the
parent array but then create a an inner
are a row 0 which is length of 5 and
then you push that into the scarf so
this is basically you know you have five
stitches on your needle to start next
one is low one knit and when the pattern
says just knit that means knit whatever
how many ever that you have on the
needle just make that knit stitch for it
so the low one is a map of row zero to
create this K STS STS is stitches and
knitting speak I guess common
abbreviations so now I can create a low
one that has a string K a five of them
because the load 0 was 5 next one is a
little so this is how it looks like in
all your life the next one is a little
more complicated and you can't meanie
solve it with map because there's so
many things going on so let's do one by
one
low two in knitting you can't create
magic numbers more magical stitches
immediately it you always inherit the
of the previous array so you create a
new array because it's on the needle
right like you can't like go from ten
stitches 200 status immediately there
will be instruction if that's needed so
there's no instruction to create a new
stitches so we'll just in create decides
from the previous array and create a
load to array and then keep the index
and then the first one is to K 2 which
means knit 2 so just you know push the
letter K to the first 2 elements of this
array the next one M 1 is make one so M
is stance will make which basically
means here please create one stitch that
didn't exist but please create it and
there's many ways to create it but
usually you pick the stitch from the
down but you know in the array it's kind
of like a splice and changing the lens
and you start to see the JavaScript the
best language to do this because you are
manipulating the size of array and
checking the size of array as you go or
wrong I learned C but I went through
like C++ class six months ago and I
learned new syntax and I was like I'm a
programmer I know the syntax I'm gonna
port this knitting program into C++ and
the first very innocent question that I
came up was like to instructor what how
do I know a links of an array in C and
how do I change the size of an array and
the instructor was like yeah about that
I now know how memory allocation works
in JavaScript it's not so the next one
now that we change the size of an array
next one is knit until 2 stitches
remaining which means until the two
empty elements left in that array just
put lipstick into that array so in this
case it's only adding one knit stitch
but legs still remains in 6 and there is
two empty element in this array and
comes and one again so now we're
changing the size of array again now the
size of array is 7 and then the last one
is knit 2 filling in those things so at
the end of this procedure my scarf array
has this 3 lows of starting with nothing
of 5 to knit 5 to knit 7 and lastly so
start with these tiny operations and
then lastly you repeat it for 20 times
and then you start to get shape of scarf
you might guess that this operation if
you continue to do it 400 times or 200
times you to get triangular scarf
however when you deal with knitting you
can see a little bit on this picture
that it's carved like making the carve
you get to deal with 5 mask or
hyperbolic geometry knitting it's not a
Euclidean space but hyperbolic space so
if you do know I still don't have the
answer for it but I do want to make this
like knitting visualizer that like
translate the knitting pattern into
actual representation of visualized
thing and if you know how to deal with
hyperbolic geometry on the 2d canvas
please do let me know because my math
understanding is not quite there yet so
what why does this leads to compiler and
DSL the domain-specific language so I
was when I started learning code I
immediately went into understanding
knitting with code 3 summers ago I took
a little challenge
of going to a little uncomfortable area
we're trying to explore this as a
artistic thing that I do and I unload
this program called school for poetic
computation it is a artists land school
in New York City where a programmers and
artists gets to go for a certain amount
of time I went for a short period of
time but there is a 10-week program and
basically it's a place you get to do a
fun [ __ ] with code and art in there I
took a class by Sarah who spoke
yesterday here called talking to
machines those [ __ ] and it was
basically a class to explore programming
language that talks to computer as a
artistic medium so we learned a lot
about domain-specific language and how
to make those things and parse her ideal
parsers and you know looking the tooling
machine and like you know a lot of
things so my project for this class was
that oh I've been thinking about
knitting with code you know looking from
like how to see meaning from the
computers point of view but what if I
can make a knitting point of view
exposed into a computer so I made a
small programming language called 64
stitches and idea was to treat a
knitting pattern that we just deciphered
it was JavaScript as a computer code so
you might see in the thing the co for
eight like quickcast on eight until the
main stitches you can kind of change and
I made interactive or Apple to change
the pattern as you change those values
in the code my graphical programming
skill was not quite there yet back then
so I decided to do a underscore and star
as a replacement for knit and purl
stitch to do represent a color
difference not be a fabric difference
the visualization for the sweater
pattern came a year later so now I can
make this like an almost realistic of
the presentation of knitting fabric but
back then I used just you know color so
the underscore represents white pick
so the asterisks represents a black
pixel so I tweeted good thing about this
is that the entire code fits in the URL
so a lot of people started to tweeting
me their code in the URL form and I made
a little bit of like a visualizer so
here's the invader that they made and
skull and cat so a lot of people got the
idea that the cast on is defines the
width of this pattern but not many
people got into this like a loop action
of the programming language that I
defined a lot of them ended up just
defining one by one pixel of the color
which is fine kind of interesting so I
use pictures to make this project Texas
is a parser generator for JavaScript
which lets you like basically generate a
parser or the compiler using a thing
called parsing expression glamour and
entire code for doing this this 64
stitches looks like this with a little
bit of JavaScript outside of this pace
so it was you know it was like a little
bit of time to learn how to do this
expression but it's kind of amazing that
these tiny bit of code can spit out a
parser that supposed a very small
programming language that was
interesting however I'm pretty much in
the school of thinking that abstraction
is a tool not magic and you have to
learn it to use it so even though I had
this interesting experience of amazing
experience of being able to create a
domain specific language for knitting I
was very frustrated that I did not
understand what goes into it I felt like
somebody told me yeah just that works as
is and just accept it as is and I know
there's many people who teach
programming till a beginner start like
you know just an abstraction is amazing
just you know don't question it and use
it and just we'll get there later I'm
the kind of person who have to
understand what those abstraction is
step by step in order to utilize those
abstractions like once I understand how
jQuery works I'm like just use jQuery
everywhere but
I understand it then I have to write a
Dom code by my hand by myself so that's
just my type of person so I got it got
me into like kind of backing idea of I
wanna make compiler so I oughta make
just like you know understand how to
make programming language work also back
then I worked at a company called
scripto which made a text editor for TV
fractions so TV producers and writers
used specific glamour to write specify
the characters and scenes and you know I
could have just been doing like making a
react component and you know doing the
UI part but because I was maybe
interested
I volunteered to do a converter of
converting those specific gamma into
Buckton I didn't know what ASD is so I
was just calling like a structures day
some data and then so that you can
convert it into leaked text or some
other format so here's the a year ago
almost of my comment to work slack but
my common code has function name lexer
and parser and I kept thinking this
sounds like computer science maybe I'm a
programming computer so you can see that
a year ago my understanding was that I
was starting to double with a lot of
blog posts and idea exposed to the idea
of computer science C compilers but I
wasn't quite there yet but I listened to
a podcast interview by a Japanese guy
who interviewed lui Yama
who it's called Li build FM but and
there they were talking about this
project that Louis did which is how I
wrote a self-hosting C compiler in 40
days and length of you goes with like so
it's kind of amazing that you made a C
compiler like how the hell did you start
it and he goes in was like well if you
think about it the specification for C
is very sad and very minimal compared to
other language and you know you just
start with day one creating string
string expressions and another little
literals
next day you add another operators and
you know Obama one by one you add
features to the C language and you know
after 40 days you get a self compiling C
code I was like okay that is really
interesting approach maybe I might be
looking at this project wrong of
thinking that I have to understand this
compiler thing in order to make a
programming language or the parser maybe
this feeling I should stir it with tiny
corner and just like start doing it
coincidentally I discovered a book
called design by numbers which is
written by John Maeda design byte
numbers is a name of the book but also
name of a programming language developed
at MIT Media Lab back in 80's 90's it is
precursor to processing and it is
designed to teach philosophy and nuts
and bolts of how programming works to
artists so the code for dbn design by
number looks like this like paper 0 P
100 line 0 0 100 and then the output of
that code the compiled the results of
that code is that image next to it the
book is beautiful book go through one by
one the first idea of what is color
what is pen what is like to put a dots
on the screen to what it's like to store
data in a valuable to what it's like to
have a loop so that you can create 100
different version of this image and if
you go cover to cover you kind of
understand the evolution of creating a
programming language much like the guy
who created this e compiler a self
compiling see you know it started with
very tiny thing into very arable at big
thing so I was like this is interesting
I went into websites to see if there's
any more resources gracing the new
version of DV and came out in 2003 that
supports a browser that you can learn
interactive code so I went in quick and
and you know of course it's Java v's so
it doesn't work it wasn't too keen on
compiling Java source code myself so I
was like I know a programming language
order the language that does this that
walks in modem browser which is SVG
could I maybe this is a good chance that
I start making my own compiler that
takes a syntax that is well defined in
the book design my numbers into a SVG
after all compiler is like taking a
sauce cord doing something and
outputting it while I was leading the
book I was taking a written code
thinking myself what it would look like
and then imagining the picture that
would come out so basically I was being
compiler so how can I make that into
code so let's do a little experiment of
being a compiler so the precursor
information that in Debian the space is
always 100 100 the corner the bottom
left corner is at 0 0 and then both of
top right corner is 100 hundred calories
defined from 0 to 100 0 is white black
is 100 there's no other color let's see
this code and think about what kind of
graphic this code will produce and this
is the exact exercise that I did like
thinking about you know I just did this
by reading this book what just happened
let's just do it again and you have
guess yeah it's good ok if you guess
this one then congratulation you just
became a compiler let's look at what go
what went into your brain by doing so so
you were given this piece of code the
string that you don't you somehow
understand the rule of the programming
language like colors and space first
thing you did probably is to define that
ok distinguish between the word and
so you divide those thing and then you
classify those as a word or number after
that given the programming rule that I
told you about the paper has a size and
the color you probably started to group
those together thinking that okay after
paper there is a color number so those
are two what one chunk
after pen there's always color so
there's another chunk and then after the
line instruction maybe there is XY
coordinate for two points to draw so
those are one chunk so you started to
goop those things together and after
that you probably change that in your
head into human readable language like
get white paper or white rectangle and
Glover black pen and draw a line in the
middle 5050 of the y coordinate from
left side x0 to right side X hundred and
compile the result it's this so you just
compiled it you draw it this is kind of
like executable that you get after
compiling C code you can give it to
anybody and everybody would say yes
there is a straight line in the middle
they don't care about what kind of code
that produce this thing but you can
share those thing and they will
everybody will get the same result so
those are the compiler defaults and you
we just did a steps that compiler takes
we just did a chunking into tokens
creating a structure changing the shape
of the structure and outputting a code
so let's look at it in computer speak in
order to make this compiler that I was
trying to make which is taking dbn
syntax and then up hitting a SVG so the
first thing that happened is
tokenization and this is the only
section of the the talk that happens
like a computer the keyword so sometimes
it's called lexical analyzer you get a
string paper 100 and then you output
things that's like a little more divided
and classified so in this case I
basically split with do the split
operation with space
and then check if it's not a number or
not and then classify it as a word or
paper so that's what we were doing on
the side shows what we just looked up
after you have those things you do thing
called parsing and when you do parsing
you create a thing called abstract
syntax tree or AST for short ast is like
map of your code so let's say by
defining things you now have a point on
the map that says here's a city office
here's a station here's a your house and
you know here's something else and by
cleaning ast you map the derivations of
those points and how those points
connect together by a load so you kind
of start to draw the map of your code so
again you have those input and you pass
it to Pasir function and you would
probably create a structured data that's
look like this so in this case I start
with a drawing as a big type at inside
of the drawing I have a call expression
of paper paper takes the arguments of
type number and in this case value is
hundred or in the the picture example
it's a zero and then once you have that
much like we change it into human
readable text you do things called
transformation so transformation is
creating a new ast so in this case in
dvn sphere idea of paper exists idea of
pen exists however in order to put those
into SVG world SVG doesn't know what
paper is or pen is maybe they have
similar understanding that is a path or
color or elect angle but you need to
translate those thing in order to make a
CG so you give those data and then
create a new SD that's more suitable for
the SVG world so I you know straight up
define tag is SVG boney has the element
of rectangle and that has the attributes
and then finally so this is what you did
was you know changing into human
readable code or human readable text
and then finally you do Co degeneration
which is creating actual SVG element so
you know again you take that new ast go
through that structure and then just you
know string concatenate make s physique
code so here is a demo that if you are
interested I have a demo online that has
a kind of like a level and you can edit
it and you can see step by step
tokenization what happened parsing ast
transformed ast what happened and then
throws you eller if something that they
don't understand happens and that's all
my github slash sbin I named it SP n
like SVG by numbers and live of not
designed by numbers so if you want to
look at those and kind of like you know
on the fingertip understands you can
look at that so by making compiler is
really fun and I everybody to do it and
here is a huge suggestion that you can
do so do you wait whoa
I write JavaScript some of you might
write JavaScript but maybe you can write
a compiler that takes a JavaScript code
and what that takes a different code and
spits out JavaScript maybe like Japanese
script so this is something I care a lot
so I use my second language and I damn
know that having a privilege of time and
money to learn English granted me a lot
more opportunity in this industry you
know it got me able to lead bleeding
edge technology documentation like you
know without waiting for somebody's
translations
it got me able to write a call for
proposal for these conference which get
me more visibility in the community you
know when we talk about code and we talk
about coding is universal everybody
should learn to code you have to realize
that the language itself you using code
like function and if and while is
English
EKOS entire each system is English
centric so maybe seven years
in United States might have easier time
both like you know that might create a
JavaScript code easily to do something
awesome but then in some same your
seven-year-old in Japan might have you
know stumbled upon this idea of what is
if what is why I didn't have to wait to
understand those English grammar first
to get it into computer programming so
those are like something that I really
care about so maybe you can those do
those things oh there is a thing called
the fee curse clip which let you like
JavaScript in Swedish and vice versa so
it's possible it's a it's possible if
you want to do it for your native
language but not only that you can do
things like emoji code write a code in
emoji that's awesome and another one is
get soaked it is a programming language
that use the code is picture so the
alignment of the color defines what kind
of operation these code needs to do and
it's not just a art project even though
it is like weird and fun and like arty
when you deal with like say GPU
accelerated kind of like a whoopsie yell
and you know try to do a quick math on
WebGL you do load data in color because
you know GPU understand image it means
is data data can be stored in the image
and you can you know do your things so
you know image as a code is a valid
thing so and conclusion I suggest that
we should all make compiler even though
you might not have project immediately
you should try because you learned a lot
of things from just building of Pilar
and here the three things I learned
after a building a compiler I'm not
saying that like the computer tells you
everything I don't believe in like AI as
a god but you do understand you do get
to learn a lot of things and learn from
computers sometimes first thing is it's
okay to start small and have a failure
thing so much like a lexical analyzer
started with just you know dividing up
the code and just classify it is it
number they didn't need to know what
happens in the next step but they just
started with very small thing and you
know let the other step worry about it
so it's IDEO K to start with small and
familiar things just start it another
one is be a good parser don't be a jerk
we sparked our message and it's just not
not just code that you write but also
the human interaction so I learned
computer programming with a lot of
people it's help like I came in I did
basic syntax but then I learned a lot of
things by asking questions and a lot of
helpful answers I get is not the answer
that I get about the things I asked it's
the thing the pointer to something else
so let's say I ask X like I don't know
why this doesn't work X I'm helpful LR
message or helpful message is that yeah
I think it doesn't work yeah that's
wrong that's not helpful but you don't
need need to solve the problem for me
but you can say something like wallets
that wouldn't work maybe you should look
up these keywords on Google or you
should look at this documentation like a
little bit of pointer to get started Elm
is a language that kind of embraced that
methodology and there is a great blog
post about compilers for humans if you
write Elm you know that when elements
rose and Eller it says it's era but you
might want to look at those things this
might be wrong you might want to cut
those things and it's very helpful so
you should write those have a message in
your code and you should be like so they
have a message when somebody ask you
questions so actually the context is
everything so much like our transformer
transform the information that was
suited for dbn world into SPG world you
need to switch the context when we are
making things when we're making software
maybe things that you've built now for
your US market might not work for your
Asian market and
you need to find somebody who is really
good at transforming those contexts and
those are really good people to have on
your team because it makes your
production course so much easier to
write they were the one who translates
everything that you need to know so be
careful of the context and be awesome
compiler if you're interested in the
things that I talked about I have a blog
post about what I did with JavaScript
code sample so do you look at those it
is the DCCC by-nc-sa so if you want to
translate those thing to different
language you can totally do that and
ping me that you did it and I will link
to it you can use your blog you can use
the github this is the latest one beep
Brazilian Portuguese B volunteers did
and you know right now it's like and
translated into five different language
so if you do speak all the language
please do help me and thank you very
much for your kind attention
[Music]
[Applause]